hey guys it's max max second in this
video I'm showing off my brand-new $492
for tonight gaming PC that is capable of
playing at full 1080p with high settings
on most of the options and with epic
view distances all while staying above a
constant 60 FPS to give you competitive
gameplay now along with this video I'm
putting together a full step-by-step
build guide so that you can build this
exact computer even if you've never
built a PC before it's gonna show you
exactly how to set it up how to install
Windows and make it ultra easy so that
anybody can do it now before we go into
fortnight and look at actual gaming
performance and see how this keeps up I
have all the parts listed in the video
description below and I also have
alternatives just in case you have a
little bit more money to spend in this
build and a lot of these parts were
chosen because they're inexpensive and
fairly high quality I've built a couple
pcs in this case and it looks really
nice for the price next we have our
motherboard n SSDs and these cost a
little bit more money than I could have
spent but I wanted to make sure that you
guys have slots for two extra RAM sticks
just in case you want to upgrade in the
future you have a wide variety of ports
on the back and along with that an m2
SSD is fast and it's very very easy to
install now for the CPU I went with an
i3 CPU it's quad-core more than enough
for pretty much all games you're not
going to bottleneck whatsoever and then
on top of that we have this graphics
card the Radeon 560 which makes this
build capable of above 60fps at 1080p
with mostly high settings in the epic
view distances which you really need if
you want to be competitive now before I
turn it over to Vadim to get into some
Fortnight I want to say please hit that
subscribe button and enables
notifications because we will have that
build guide coming out along with a wide
variety of different tech videos however
team take it over hey guys it's vadim so
we're here in fortnight in the settings
and we're gonna start off with a medium
preset but we're gonna switch the view
distance to epic and we're also turning
off motion blur so everything's gonna
look nice and sharp so let's get in the
game the graphics just look horrible
right now but thankfully we're not going
to be on these settings for long
just showing off how high frame rates we
can get with this cheap budget build so
as you guys can see we're getting very
good frame rates around 150 right now
but as you guys can son of a gun kill
this dude kill this dude so as you guys
saw our frame rates are very high but
the graphics quality suck so let's kick
it up and see what we can get so now I
hit the high preset and as you guys can
see the 3d resolution went to 1080p
everything here is on high I'm still
gonna switch it to epic and we still
have motion blur off so right away the
graphics quality looks a lot better
everything looks nice and sharp and
detailed and I'm very surprised by the
where is he
haha I was who I said do it that's he
dude Oh
86 come on anyways as you guys saw the
FPS is doing pretty well sitting around
55 this is very smooth I'm not noticing
any lag spikes or any frame drops or
anything like that so here we are back
in the settings and this time we're
going to turn the shadows completely off
because to be honest they don't really
matter when you're playing competitively
and we're also gonna turn the
anti-aliasing down to medium alright
oh come on Wow daddy alright so as you
guys can see we're sitting at around 70
FPS that's a pretty good jump from what
we had before and everything's looking
very smooth and to be honest the quality
still looks just as good as before so
I'm thinking these settings are doing
pretty well alright got me come on dude
what's up okay so the frame rates are
looking really good we're up in the 70s
and 80s and everything's looking very
smooth I'm not noticing any drop frames
and that says a lot because I'm used to
a display that runs out 144 Hertz so
what's great about these settings is
that I've got the viewing distance set
to epics so I can see basically
everything oh come on I almost had him I
almost had him oh it's it next up is the
me black ops 4 so make sure you guys
subscribe so you don't miss out on that
video
get up ah joking 10 HP whoa got him as
you guys saw the gameplay was very
smooth their frame rates were above 60
the whole time which is very impressive
for this budget build four hundred and
ninety six dollars right four hundred
ninety two dollars now just for kicks
less that's at how this bill will do
planning at 4k graphics settings so I'm
starting to see some drop frames but
I've got to say everything looks so
amazing so crisp sharp and detailed
we're hitting as low as 24 FPS sometimes
and it's definitely not a smooth gaming
experience now keep in mind this is
right out of the box we haven't done any
overclocking at all now if you do want
to play at high resolution like a 4k I
would recommend spending some extra cash
on a better graphics card so for this
build without doing any overclocking
these are the graphics settings that I
would recommend we're at 1920 by 1080 P
the 3d resolution matches that we're at
epic viewing distance shadows are off
anti-aliasing is on medium
textures effects post-processing is all
on high and motion blur is off alright
guys so let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below even if you're not
gonna be building one of these make sure
you guys hit that subscribe button
enables notifications we will have that
step-by-step build guy that's gonna make
it super easy for anybody that wants to
build their first PC to be able to do so
without having to go and buy a premade
PC that's gonna cost more money and give
you less performance once again all the
parts are listed in the description
below along with alternatives if you
have a little bit more money to spend
and some accessories and peripherals
like some monitor suggestions if you're
gonna be building one of these pcs thank
you guys for watching this one max of
max tech and I'll see you in the next
one